so efe
jose miguel zavala zavala that I have seen
that in the pool
d
thanks for in here
to fans to the rhythm of Hispanic presentation
of things or hard to miss a lot well
then I am going to talk
about what I am going to talk about is they are
results  more than results they are things
that we apply to hps what is hp is high
performance computing is hp what is that
is high performance computing
out what we do
at the barcelona supercomputing center in
the apartment where I am is
we simulate fluid dynamics which is
fluid dynamics
anything like this
from the air that circulates inside
an airplane to the air that you
breathe then once  that since they
have already done their simulation with all the
physics that you want, then
comes the analysis, this is
what sells to companies, a company
comes and tells us  it says we want to do this
so we show them the type of
work we have done this is
like aspiration they are particles that
travel through the trachea
so I am going to talk about this then the first
idea that it is hpc think of it this
way divide and  you will overcome that the idea that
I want that I would like
then as we do the modeling of
practically any physical thing that
can be modeled or that could be modulated
in the future the first thing we do this
is an example is very particular
of the modeling of the heart
here in the first  and in this first
part what we see what we are three
go to the doctor they take a
tomography and from that
tomography we can process the data
that is taken from there and obtain a
geometric representation of that from
the heart or from the  lungs or some
specific part of the body this is a
geometric representation this is what
the computer we are going to give you the first
ingredient then what  what we do is
the space that geometry occupies
we are going to divide it
further into small geometric objects almost
always not always they are tetrahedrons
triangles in three dimensions
on those tetrahedrons it is on where
we do mathematical operations once
we have our first component what
we are going to do now  it is that we want to
do that we want to solve that I want to
solve about that heart I want to see
how it beats in particular that is
the example that is put there so
I have to solve a set of
equations these equations in this case
represent me as
a solid  it moves in a few words
once I have the equation what I do is
pass it to some mathematical representation
and after that mathematical representation it
is what the computer already
understands and that what I want to solve
so in this case it is that those
mathematics are matrices  almost everything
that can start from a geometry
like this one that I just gave you  and show
ends up being matrices so I
have matrices of millions of with
millions of numbers that what I want to
do is solve the
simple one simply once simply good
once I already have my matrix and that it has already been
solved not with matlab because these
are already millions  I can have I can
do a post-processing and an analysis of
the data that I want to obtain here
we can once we have the model
validated and working we can simulate
what will be the effect of putting certain
drugs or putting certain
chemical elements or for example that
a  pacemakers we could simulate the
effect that a pacemaker has when
we put it in some part of the
heart
additionally what I am going to
talk about now is visualization this
particular visualization was made by my
boss
a few years ago and he won a very
important super award  complete in the usa
then the talk is going to be life
as follows i am going to give you an
introduction to one more  well a little
idea of ​​what in my opinion is to use
python in supercomputers and then
demonstrate that it is a supercomputer
that is hpc hpc high performance
computing
the second part is going to be oriented
to what the presentation
is about rather it is visualization using two
tools for view and blender
so
ok now that it is a computer this
supercomputer marenostrum is an
example there are several in the world there is the one
we have here in barcelona it
has more than 165,000 processors well
the one that is going is the one that they are installing
now it can do 11,000 trillion
operations per second and it costs
around 30 million euros
so this is the little toy with
which we solve the
matrices that I was telling you a moment ago
now these computers that are a
set of computers that are connected
by nodes that are connected to
through practically infiniband infiniband
is what it allows is low
latency
in the interconnection of all the nodes
that is the main component that
supercomputers have differences
from some classic clusters with which they
could build with rocks or some type
of cluster d a little not so done it is not
in hpc now to handle this type of
computers what is usually
used not always but almost always
a message protocol a message
sending protocol that what does it mean each
node of the computer is
somewhere and is connected through the
infiniband so what we
need is that these nodes be
communicate with each other what we have to
do is send messages then the mp
and this library what it allows us to do is
send messages through the
computer so now how
do we do this we have a we have a
problem a particular problem like the ones that
show the  heart
or some turbine or or whatever you want
then what we do is break it into
pieces we divide it into as many pieces as  or
processors we want to use or
can use and each processor is going to
carry out a part of the solution
so now since each each node
has a part of the problem then what
we need now is certain parts
of those operations need the
information of the others  nodes then
what and that is
where that is where the mp and the mp come in and what
it is going to do as I told you at that
time is to send the information between
the nodes
this is information because certain parts
of the matrix in this particular case
then I put  small snippets
of code for you
to notice but no idea what
is being done so if we
want to send a message from a
processor process or one from processor 2
this is the mp pencil and then it
what we say is processor 0 is going to
send a number in this case the minus 1
to processor 1 to processor 1 is what
I want to do in this case
with kilo and ran this prog  branch and what
it gives me is a processor one has received
a -1 that is in general what is done
is in broad strokes is what we do
now the part the part that seems
very interesting to me is a time for each
time this is known with  the dog with lo
can also be compact so there
is already an api created on
a payton module created on a
mp and that allows us to do this
exactly this new process what is
very interesting in this case is that because
we can send almost
we can send anything native to payton
through the library so in this
example that I put there what we
are sending is a dictionary it is
quite interesting thank you
so I don't know what the performance
of that is but it seems to me at least very
interesting
so now sending and receiving
information that way is a bit
boring it
doesn't allow us to do much
then aside from
that idea of ​​just sending and receiving
rec  ibr information what we
do is there are many operations
so what we can do is for
example here we have in a node I have
certain information and what I want to do
is distribute it to all the nodes
so that allows me to make a commitment uses
and scatter I have  information in each
node and I think what I want is for everyone to
have the same information I can
do it through an e-mail there is today
geithner I want to make a reduction a
reduction of some certain
mathematical operation through all the nodes
I can do that  through a use they
reduce this in this example what
I have is a vector of different
nodes and what I do is a sum over
each component of the node and that is
stored in a root in a
particular node or I can do  the sum that
everyone has that information then
from the composition of this type of
operations
I can solve even more
complicated things like the ones that we show
Just a moment ago
I gave you a particular example
that seemed quite interesting to me in
the case of big data things, well, it
seems interesting to me, I'm not an expert in
that, in fact,
it looks very bad, I'm very sorry,
this is an example of  climate data from
the noaa the new one is
the center of the atmosphere and oceans of the
usa so what i am going to do here is
i have the information
of all the weather
of various stations around the usa about the
weather in different points in the usa and in
all the times in all I want to
know is what is the maximum temperature
per year in through all those data
so here I have this the structure
of the data this is supposed to
be disaggregated here but this would come in a
single line
I want to know  I have the geographic information for you
and I have the temperature
so now this information comes
as I told you a moment ago it
comes by year by season through
all of the United States and it comes in
small files here what I
was showing you was precisely those files
here just what you don't see is how many
files there are for 1910 which are very few they
are as
it seems to me that they are from the returns
but for 1950 which is the case I
am going to show you the  At the moment I already have
around more than 100,000, well, almost a
hundred thousand, 100,000 files, 25 terabytes of
information, so I thought it would be
interesting to solve something like
this, so I usually copied this example from
this hadoop book, they embedded the resort,
I'm going to solve it  with send
com python to see
what I can do compact or mt I paint myself
is the idea is just what has just been
commented I have all the data I read the
data as I read it I get the
information from each file then it is from
the information of which file  I can
get
the temperatures in a specific year
so that will be a mapping once
I have this information I can now
these of these vectors that I have
here to get what is the
maximum temperature of the whole year
here I put two parts of the
code that I made this is I will have being the
local part this what it does is I
distributed all the files that I
have through all the processors that I
want to use so now this part
what  going to do is read the files and
find the information that I have
now I particularly use
payton dictionaries with where the kin is
going to be the year and where the values ​​are going
to be vectors these are going to be a reading country
once I have this  for each
processor I can operate on all
the years that
each of the processors has that processor and find the
maximum perez a local maximum ok once
you have the local maximum I can
do a job or reviews like the
one shown is a moment  to find
the max over all the processors
you are using so
this is this is a little example here
is how you run stand and run
this is for one processor using  python
the code the year that I use and
especially the files that I am going to
use this what I show you well
what we are here I am very sorry that you do
not see it is that the temperatures that they
give me are the same that they give to al  from the
book to validate what I am doing
now I did this for this corresponds
to 1900
using a processor it takes us
approximately
no time does not come out but
then exactly the same but with
four processors the result has
to be the same obviously if it does not lose
validity  what we are doing has
to be the same I use a processor or
use in 20 million processors
now as it has been shown the one from 1910
only has a few files but the one
from 1950
has here it has 2,500 files too
late to run on one processor
yes  I'm not wrong 1 point 42 seconds if
I run with four processors this one
takes 50 seconds to process
this one has much more files than the
previous one
now
now  to this one in particular for 1950 not the
entire decade of the 50s only for 1950
now for the entire decade of 1950
we have that there are 25
25,000 files more or less with 4.5
gigabytes of information so
we apply our our
our method again
but now for the decade  from 1990
to 1990 we have 23 gb of 23 gigabytes of
information and almost 100,000 files
this executed on a single processor
takes me for a single year it takes me
approximately 10 minutes now I
do it for the whole decade using 128
processors and it takes me approximately
2 minutes
i would love to compare it to hadoop but i
have no idea how to use so i do
n't know i don't know how good or bad this is but
well this shows what of course
it can be done maybe
even much more can be done
optimize the code in many more parts
but well, we can leave that for a
future job, now this use
to solve big problems is already
being done by a colleague of
mine to  solve
oil fields what they do is they look
for oil fields and in particular
my colleague what he did is write his
code that solves
electromagnetic equations
using employee in place by pact this
curve that I show here what
speed up is what it means  the speed up
is if I use if it takes me a second
to execute a program or a certain
part of the program in a single node
if I use two I have to close
half ok spirals of two if I use
four the spiral is of four ok
then what  what it is showing here is
the speed up to 1920 processors this
is the ideal so here it is already
beginning to separate a little but
everything continues to be seen that it is quite a
thing what this shows is that the
approximation that I crudely showed you
using begins with  payton to analyze
the data can be used in real problems
in real applications
now having shown that it
can be done with a compact  demonstrate
that it is done once I have already
collected everything solved all my
equations also solved
my code is validated then as I said
I am going to show you all
well my experience is in two
programs in particular
for iun that is used to analyze
practically any scientific data
is what  which is mostly used and
blender blender has been like 3d max
but opensource the same ideas that
apply blender can be applied 3d max
than three others is used to make
movies if you look there 3d max
miami but not maya maya 3d now they don't see
honor for  someone else but
today to some someone else to break
then the visualization as well as the
resolution of the equations that
I told you about your moment is based on
geometry as I showed you that moment I
can have the heart
and divide it into small triangles
once I have those triangles
but also the emissions are also
operating on these triangles because  and it is
important to understand this because if
you control
these formats they can practically be
the dissolution of whatever you want
but literally whatever you want
is based on very simple ideas these are
the objects that I can
visualize from that I can build  all
the movies that I have shown you at the
time, so how is it built that
I have to understand about them the first thing
is that I have to create I have to
know what the vertices of that
geometry are ok once I have those
vertices I need to connect the
connectivities of that geometry which are
the connectivities I need to know
the axes how the axes
are connected how the faces are connected
and how the whole cell is connected in zinc
ok so
a face to face 124 is formed by
this 1
perrone 43 it would be all this face that
I have back ok and this cell 1-2-3-4
represents the entire youtube cell ok
from that information that I have
obviously  the only thing I have is that
this is repeated I have 20 million
cells this has to be done 20
million times it
is very simple good relatively and
once the idea is already understood to
perón properties are also applied
to each node
properties are added because you want to visualize the
temperature throughout the entire car if you
wanted to visualize how
the temperature is distributed throughout the
body then the little hand that I created
over my entire body in each tetrahedron
in each tau node put the temperature and
in  based on that I can color all
the colors that come although they will be the
movies these of whatever they want from
marvel they are based on something like that right
now the show version is
a little code they use 90 here now
I'm going to show you the examples now that
we're done
From this little triangle, all I have
to do is once I have the
sessions and the connectivity, I
already use the app and very particularly
d  and in this case of bebeteca that you go here
is the base for view
to be able to build a simple triangle it
is very simple I tell him I have the
coordinates he passed it on as
he asked me in this case I create the cell
a list of cells  I pass a simple
cell in this case and I pass all the
points that I have there, which in this case
are 4 to define a to define a
tetrahedron and that is all I have to
do to be able to define a
boring triangle until there is a good one the same
idea we are going to apply it to blender
blender now is the time to show you
I tell you it is used to make movies and
you see it is a very very
interesting thing because it turns out that you
go to the blender api and you already understood
what I just told you  well, in
a few lines they already have their
triangle inside blender now that it
allows me once I have it already
inside blender grande it allows me to do
ray tracing rendering it allows me to put textures that
is it allows me to do  er a
more realistic visualization that is what I want to
get to the idea itself so with a
small example it
is a rough example these are cells
that are traveling through a
square vein because it is an experiment that
a friend of mine reproduced passed me the  data
and I assembled it here but you can see how
the cells travel so well your
data works well in a square vein
and it seems a bit strange with a cube in the
middle but well that's physics if you do
the physics
then now now I'm going to  show
the most interesting examples
if you have doubts here is that they were going to
say
then this is an example in which
this is a geometry of Greenland it
is loaded in exactly the same
way
the little triangle the little triangle we are
here also now it is the little triangle
with him with  the ten lines of code
that you pass to them just do the loop and they
would have the geometry of greenland at
these are the temperatures over
through all of all
of to  do euro online
now as I say this is boring
the example of blender
this is the triangle I make it run the
same with the paktika interface that
wants to record as you can see
here I have the camera a light
and this is the triangle that I just
inserted  exactly the same coordinates
so here I can do the
rendering
it shows me what you see it doesn't look very
good
what happens is that the first part
is to enter the data once you
enter the data the rest is already an artistic thing
hello
they have slipped they put the cameras to
move the light they put colors
to compose whatever you want and you
can do this that I am showing is
exactly how the heart is made
that I showed you your moment or the glass from the
beginning this is also the  part
this is how it is made
of what
the example of the cells consists of
and it is loaded exactly the same
simply with a loop
and we can also do the rendering
that s  and it's going to look very bad but well
here what you can see
this is supposed to be a trip from
the square because the camera is the one
I have to be in this part
here
so what comes is what what
what  What the camera sees is done, so I
do
n't have a
cell phone here, let's
wait a second, I put my camera in place,
what I can do is exactly this,
and to the animation,
ok, I'll tell you, they put the artistic part on it
, they feel like a long time, put them
reid in the bed of  everything and the heart with
the turbine whatever you want
now
and thank you very much
[Applause]
jones
hello thank you tried to ask in
Spanish
[Music]
it costs me walter klein from payton life
for fire version in envigado for bio
endurance not of law but to talk about
formalization  water
but don't
send for peace
that
's the water
where you are just you
and I'll put up with you analyzer tits
with webber
for me to
fight
for what
and
[Music]
the sun
josh olson sends and form
i
problem of multi physics can  It is that
simply the transport of a
molecule that has a relationship
along
some fluid dynamics and some
chemistry
the transport of an
activity molecule to a decay
understanding multi physics is a
word that sounds familiar to you
in fact but the question is related
if I can do it with the pp or we can
do it in the bcc well, I can do it myself,
for
example, an
example of the heart is not simply
dynamic physics or there was
ok in the particular case the heart
that I showed you what is solved  that was
a first approximation the heart was solved
the equations of the movement
of the heart but they are the mechanics the
heart had no fluid that was
solved five years ago in the
apartment now it is possible to do
multi physics that what is there is
therefore multi physics  it is I solve the
heart plus the fluid inside then the
movement of the heart causes there to be a
movement of the fluid that we can
do in fact that is what I e  In
particular I do in my doctorate so
if you are interested then I can
tell you a little more in fact the
library that developed allowed actor
ado
and maybe this has a
strong code in code in python
through mp and we can send
information  from one code to another ok
so that means that I can
explain it can be any application
that you are interested in that
is solving one physics or another or for
example something that I did recently it was
good they are a bit it is josh hug well
a problem
in the code we have that stanford
trans and what I wanted to do a
real time analysis of the data so what
I did was use pie and forfeit to
send it still to a payton script and
analyze it in real time with a wipe
then that guy  of things are the ones that
can be done because it
asks you which was the one you are referring to,
lost a bit when how
the graphics are generated in blender from the
re  results of the simulations how it
happens to the data is the format that you
here not having now now I will answer you
what you do is use the api from
here
use the api from d
that blender has
this amount that I have that I have here is
this  script is read by blender ok so
what I wanted to show was that if you
have the information of the goring of
the cells or of the faces if you
use the tombstone
for view from vtech you can do the
beckham rendering for view but with
the same idea with the same concepts
simply seeing the details of the
particular action you write
you put your data in the
corresponding script and you run it
through blender sorry
now yes you do attitudes as you
run it through blender  mine here I
show
you what I do here is this line here
you see it I call blender and he passed the
script
what happens all that information is the
writing that is giving the data to
learn in it I
don't know  write to files or anything
just good it depends on you the
case that happened to me my friend what he did
is a bit of a process using the
praise script
all his data he passed a format
later but he passed it a
paita script and then  The
other way is that if you have
very large data, every time you
have a frame you read little by
little,
thanks for
a question, when it is written to
visualize simulation data, for
example,
you have to make two representations,
I understand, that is, it is to represent the
data.  About this data first
to simulate and I am going to translate this
structure into one,
that is, a structure to be able to
visualize if there are like two
representations or it
is the same one to see the two are based on
representing space
as a set of small geometries
both of us then what we do
to simulate is divide the space into
tetrahedrons or
into squares cubes
and as you can see if you look here at what I
put
in the previous spla
here the paralysis is but the
appearance the visualization is based
on exactly the same thing we
solve
exactly
you have to understand
this operations of everything what to do here
to convert it into a matrix
and that's it but the concept this is the idea
with you that  give
yes to do both pass a simulation
and one to make a visualization
another question is gray and there is a
huge change between an extra cheer crit and a
danish after the crit
for freeze when in doubt it will be
fine
for view if I'm not mistaken what it
does  is to load the geometry the topology
the connectivities at each time step
then if you mean that if
the mesh is deformed
you can deform if for the mesh to be deformed
visually your data had to
be deformed another thing that can happen
is that  lose elements that more or less
is what you tell me, that is, then
a refined mesh you add
elements explained to this question
ok you don't have to be an interpolation
you would have to question the data yes it
answers soon
then then you don't understand I
don't understand the question the tape
I hope that the kers asks how to simulate
it how to visualize it
in the stoppage
is that we depend ok
first if you have a structured mesh
and unstructured the numerical methods
you apply are different if you have
a structure you have to use
finite difference if you have a mesh
structure a structure has to use
baynat element volume element
then it is already there the
approximations are different
we don't know if that
ok, once you have that clear, in the end there will
practically always be matrices left,
so if you focus your
appearance on the matrices, then what
you are going to paralyze is the matrix and
abstract from how you have made the
discrete solution of yourself as  them
because of the methodology you use to
solve your physics ok now it is
implicit explicit  or
that also depends on how to solve the
matrix as evolutions in a time
also then there are a lot of details
between having it structure of our
shutter
explain
[Applause]